remembering princess diana 25 years
after her tragic death welcome to
entertainment tonight you know it's hard
not to think about her sons william and
harry on a day like today yeah and to
wonder what diana would think of their
current relationship we've got new
details about the prince's royal rift as
the world honors the people's princess
[Music]
my mother instilled in me
and in all of us a drive to speak up and
fight for a better world i'm appalled at
the dangers young people face on the
streets
and how vulnerable they are to
exploitation
we have all been trying to help william
and harry come to terms with the
devastating loss
there isn't a day during the past two
and a half decades where i haven't
thought about the mark she left not only
on me and my brother but on all of our
lives
i give thanks that i'm lucky enough to
be her son and i got to know her for 15
years that i did
flowers photos and even a diana tribute
cake visitors paid their respects today
remembering diana outside her former
home in central london she smothered us
with love that's for sure a source tells
e.t prince william and prince harry will
observe the anniversary in private and
while their relationship remains
strained they are both dedicated to
carrying on diana's legacy i wish you
all the strength
to continue in your most important work
as a husband and a parent my mother's
voice is even stronger in my life
and there's more drama today courtesy
meghan markle a source tells et that the
royal family is disappointed by her
recent comments telling the cut magazine
she's still healing from her time with
the royals she's also talking about it
on her podcast if there's any time in my
life that it's been more focused on my
race it's only once i started dating my
husband
we're told quote there is a loss of
trust with megan and they are distressed
that after stepping back from the royal
family claiming a need for privacy she
continues to publicize family matters in
public were you having suicidal thoughts
yes
all this playing out amid new concerns
about the queen's health for the first
time during her 70-year reign queen
elizabeth will appoint the new prime
minister next week at balmoral her
castle in scotland where she's been
staying rather than at buckingham palace
where the ceremony has traditionally
been held a source tells e.t the 96 year
old monarch has been using a cane and
the royal household is making sure she
remains comfortable given her health
issues
you